[موسيقى]
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيه بودكاست وانا
راويه العلمي
اهلا وسهلا فيكم متابعينا الكرام في حلقه
جديده من برنامج كلام منطقي حلقتنا اليوم
حلقه خاصه جدا جدا جدا بستضيف فيها مجموعه
من زملاء الدرب الطويل درب العربيه وطبعا
كله هذا بمناسبه الانطلاقه العشرين او
الذكرى العشرين لانطلاقه العربيه بحب ارحب
وارحبوا معي بزملائي طبعا الست منتهى
الرمح يغني عن التعريف الدكتور طالب كنعان
قصه سمر جابر وست ميسون عزام اهلا وسهلا
انا مش عم بستضيفكم انا انتم كمان رح
تستضيفوني احنا مع بعض بدنا نروح مشوار في
شارع روح العربيه
راح يكون ممتع رح يكون ممتع فعلا 20 سنه
فتره طويله جدا عمر انا بحس انه عمر كثير
شغلات صارت انا بقول 20 سنه بالارقام
بالعربيه الانجازات تتعدى
[موسيقى]
الاحداث انا كنت حابه اسال لانه انا طبعا
بعرف انا كنت موجوده من قبل ما لاني كنت
بي ام بي سي اف ام فكنت موجوده من قبل لسه
ما تنطلق العربيه وبعدين يعني مباشره بدات
العمل مع العربيه حبيت اعرف كل حدا فيكم
زملائي الاعزاء
ليش العربيه لمنتهى اخترتي العربيه انك
تبلشي معها بالانطلاقه العربيه كانت بتمثل
لي رؤيه جديده متجدده لقراءه الخبر وقراءه
ما وراء الخبر
رؤيه مختلفه عما هو كان معروف بالموضوع
موجود بالعالم العربي في ثقه ولدتها قبل
ما انزل كنا نحكي قبل شوي ثقه ولدتها
الشركه الام اللي هي الام بي سي انها
اطلقت المنصه الاخباريه لها التلفزيونيه
العربيه
فبحكم معرفتنا بتاريخ الام بي سي انا كان
عندي ثقه مطلقه انه هذا المشروع رح ينجح
وراح ينجح
بالاداره اللي كانت مصره على ان تظهر بشكل
جديد ومختلف عن ما هو موجود على الساحه
انذاك احنا بنحكي على 2003
في صوت اخر في صوت للجمهور يجب ان يسمع في
توجه اخر في العالم في عالم الاعلام
الاخباري كانت العربيه في البدايات يعني
في محاوله لتاسيس قرب اكثر من الجمهور
وحديث اكثر عن الجمهور
وامالهم طالب طالب وانت كمان يعني في لك
وضع خاص ايضا انت كنت اول يعني مذيع اول
نشرا انطلقت فيها العربيه راح اجي لهاي
النقطه بس بدي اعرف ليش العربيه ليكي انا
اول شيء شكرا على الاستضافه ليش العربيه
لانه انا كنت اشتغل بمحطه محليه وحتى
كمان زميلتنا سومار اسمها ناشونال في
لبنان فكنا بحاجه الى فضاء اوسع فضاء اكبر
بيعطيك هذه المساحه
وكان دائما العين على مجموعه الام بي سي
متل ما قالت منتهى قد ما لك
حضور وانا بوصف انتقال من محطه محليه الى
محطه بوزن العربي وبحجم العربيه كيف كانه
انتقال الانسان يعني من الارض الى سطح
القمر لانه انا جيت على عالم
على
مجموعه من التقنيات ما كنت شايفها
المجموعه من الخبرات ما كنت شايفها لانه
لما بتشتغل بالنطاق المحلي والوطني بتكون
الخبرات محدوده اما بتشوفي مجموعه مجموعه
اول شيء من الجنسيات زملاء من الجنسيات
مختلفه بتشوفي تقنيات الخبر مختلفه
لوجستيا بتشوفي شغلات
كتير منك متعوده عليها فكان تحدي كثير
كبير وانا يعني لما انضميت كان تقولي يعني
27 سنه
[موسيقى]
ليصبح على مدار الساعه
هلا اكيد انا اعطتني العربيه شيء يمكن لا
انساه
مدى حياتي انه انا اعطتني فرصه وشرف انه
اطلق قناه العربيه وانا اشكر بعد يعني
[موسيقى]
2003 الساعه الثانيه بعد الظهر بس وصلت
انا
القناه اول شيء بيبدا ايه من الذكر الحكيم
بعدين بشوف جميع مجلس الاداره كنا على
الطابق الرابع بس باستوديو مختلف لانه
بيجي مجلس اداره كله بعدين كان في مجلس
مستشارين من 20 شخص بعدين بيجوا بعض
الامراء السعوديين بيجوا بعض الشيوخ من
الذي نرى مش باستوديو بوجهي
وصراحه عم بيشجعوني انه حتى يعني موجه
تحيه للشيخ وليد ابراهيم رئيس الاداره لكن
عم يعمل لي هيك هو الاستاذ علي الحديسي
انه يعني
فكمان حسيت قديش هاي اللحظه
بيعرف طلبت من الاستاذ صلاح قلت له بدي
اكتب
اهو فكتبت مقدمه صغيره شي حوالي 30 ثانيه
انا كتبتها وبنهيها بقول لن تكون العربيه
رقما زائدا في فضاء الاعلام لا الدولي ولا
العربي والله ولي التوفيق والان الى
النشره الاولى وبطلق النشره الاولى ساتذكر
هذه اللحظه انه انا اطلقت محطه بهذا الوزن
وبهذا الحجم واعطتني الكثير الذي لا يمكن
ان انسى اكيد وعتبنا جميعا الكثير الذي لا
يمكن ان ننسى ثمار ليش العربيه انت كمان
كنت في محطه مع طالب
بالاول وبعدين انتقلت لابو ظبي
وقت لي قالوا انه في محطه اخباريه بدها
تيجي على دبي كان الاسم ام بي سي انو شيء
ام بي سي لان اسم العربيه ولوجو العربيه
نوضع نحن وبقلب المؤسسه يعني بنفس التاريخ
اللي جاء فيه طالب
بسبتمبر 2002 كنت انا موجوده كان استديو
العربيه حجار
تغطيه حرب اعين العالم كله عليها
والانصارنا هذا الحدث هو اللي دفعك
والعربيه اللي طليتي انت منها مع هيدا
الحدث انه العالم عم نشوف لغه جديده عم
نشوف حديث جديد منطق جديد صوره جديده
ونقاش جديد العالم بطلت انه لا ما بدنا
نفس الريق وهي يمكن كل هاي المرحله
بالاعلام كانت مرحله فاصله ما بين الطريقه
التقليديه وما بين اول خطوه تجاه الحداثه
خلينا نقول يعني
الحدث العراقي سرع من الانطلاقه لانه كان
عنا كل المعلومات والمعطيات انه سيكون
هنالك حدث كبير جدا غير من مشهد الشرق
الاوسط فكان يمكن التسريع في الانطلاق
ميسون كان عندنا وقت بس التجريبي المفروض
نضل نشتغل عليه لفتره اطول كان في قلق حتى
من الاداره ومجلس انه كيف فينا نطلع واحنا
لما خلصناش مرحله البث التجريبي لكن الحمد
لله كانت تجربه كثير مهمه انه طلعنا
وقلعنا يعني بهديك الفتره بس ليش العربيه
انا كنت اسمع على فكره كنت بالام بي سي اف
ام وكنا عم نعمل كمان راديو جديد منبثق عن
الام بي سي اف ام اسمه بانوراما راديو
بانوراما وكان راديو اخباري وكنا احنا
كمان عم نعمل بس تجربه انا كنت مذيعه
ومنتجه اخبار بالراديو نعمل بث تجريبي
وبرضو انطلقنا بثلاثه ثلاثه نفس انطلاق
العربيه بانوراما بانوراما اف ام ولكن انا
كنت اسمع طبعا وراء الكواليس كنت اطلع هيك
استرق النظر للاستوديو عم ببنوا فيه
العربيه وامتى رح تطلعوا جابوا مذيعين
جداد وكذا
وكنا نسمع كنت اسمع اه لا في مذيعه جديده
جايه من لندن من لندن
هلا انا بقول مش ليش العربيه بقول ليش مش
العربيه
كانت كل الاجواء المحيطه بتدعم هاي القناه
الجديده انه تطلع وباريحيه ليش
منتهى وكل ذكرنا الام بي سي جروب الام بي
سي كان حلم اي اعلامي انه ينضم لالها
الشيخ وليد الابراهيم مع الرؤيه تعيته
وانطلاقته الفضائيه اول محطه فضائيه عربيه
تطلع
بزخم كثير كبير كسرت ابوهات كتير كبيره
كونه ايضا سعودي ويطلع بمحطه تكسر كل
القيود اللي كانت مفروضه على المحطات
المحليه اللي موجوده بعالمنا العربي هاي
اعطت اول كارت بلانش للعربيه انه تنطلق
شغله ثانيه
الاختيارات مش عشان بدي اكبر فينا احنا
الاختيارات والدعم الذي قدم للتيم كله ما
بحكي بس عن الوجوه اللي طلعت بالعربيه
بحكي حتى عن فريق العمل الكامل اللي كان
ورانا كان جميل جدا خلقه لغه واحده
استخدمناها كلنا وثقافه واحده قدرنا بفتره
وجيزه ويمكن عشان ما ضلتنا هي الام بي سي
ساعدت انه تنغرز فينا ونقدر نطلع بهاي
القوه اللي طلعنا فيها رغم انه حرب كانت
كتير اكبر مننا فبالنهايه احنا العربيه
كبرت فينا
واتسعت افاقها مع الزملاء الموجودين واحنا
كبرنا واحنا كتير بالفعل شو بتذكروا من
حرب العراق بهاي الانطلاقه وبهذا التوتر
يعني لما انا بفكر بعشرين سنه في كتير
شغلات
في بعض الاحيان بتضلها ثابته وفي كثير
شغلات يمكن الاكثر هو اللي بيتغير التغيير
هو
الغالب متذكرين شيء من الحرب اكثر حدث
يعني مجموعه من الاحداث وان كانت مثل ما
قالت ميسون ماساويه
هلا بعدين بتصير تشعري انه الماساه لما
هلا مثلا بشوف الحرف في اوكرانيا بتشوفي
مثلا مبنى مدمر او لما بصير بدك تحطي حالك
محلهم بس قبل كنا عم نغطي وانه في حرب
ضخمه بحجم الحرب في العراق يعني من
المشاهد اللي انا بتضلها ذاكرها دخول
الدبابات الامريكيه على ساحه الحريه بغداد
ويومها انزال اسقاط التمثال يعني هايدي
مثلا من لما اجينا خبر انه والله تنظيم
داعش قتل زميلتنا اطوار
وبطريقه كتير شنيعه ومؤذيه كمان كنا على
الهواء منغطي
تخطيط ابو غريب
[موسيقى]
رئيس الوزراء اللبناني الاسبق رفيق
الحريري كمان كنا كنت موجود انا كنا
موجودين على الهواء وبتعرفوا بصير بدك
تفتح الهوا وتشوفي بهذا الحجم مثلا انه في
شيء او مثلا بتشوف الطيران الاسرائيلي او
المدافع الاسرائيليه عم تضرب مطار بيروت
كمان كنا وقت
وهكذا بتشوفي محطات مثلا تنحي الرئيس حسني
مبارك عم بيقول انه
قررت تنح مقتل العقيد معمر القذافي
لانه انا عملي من وقت ما دخلت على العربيه
كان اكثر برامج برامج يعني فيها بعد
اخباري مثل طبعا اخيره السلطه الرابعه
اللي هو بيستعرض اقوال الصحف سواء العربيه
والاجنبيه وبعديها صباح العربيه اول ما
نقلت على الاخبار اللي هو كان باواخر 2011
او ربما باول 2012 انا اللي كنت على
الهواء لاول مره وانا لسه بتعامل جديد مع
الاخبار كشاشه كان مقتل القذافي
مشاهدينا معنا الان من صرت مفدى العربيه
احمد
ما هي الانباء ماذا يقال هل تاكدت
الانبياء الانبياء عن اعتقال معمر القذافي
[موسيقى]
يمكن ما بين علي ولكن توقعي وقع المشهد
ويعني وكنت مش عارفه كيف بدي يعني ايش
المفروض احكي في مرات
مقتل الرئيس رفيق الحريري اغتيال كنت على
الهواء كان معنا
نشره عاديه
وطلع الانفجار ببيروت طبعا وقت اللي طلع
الانفجار ابعد شيء على راسك انه اوكي
الوضع بلبنان
منه كان ستيبل او شي بس ابعد شي عن راسك
كانه يجي يقولوا لك انه انقتل رفيق الحرير
[موسيقى]
انفجار قويا هزا اليوم منطقه شاطئ بيروت
ولم يرد مزيد من التفاصيل بعد حتى الساعه
كانت اول محطه بتذيع خبر مقتل الرئيس رفيق
الحريري كانت العربيه
قالوا لي انقطع رفيق الحريري كملت الحوار
العاجل ما زادتم كملت الحوار انه شو
بتعتقد يكون هذا الضربه ليش بهالوقت كيف
بعدني بتذكر انه في جلسه مجلس نواب كان
ظاهر هو منا وكان في مشكل صار بقلب الجلسه
على امور سياسيه وامور اقتصاديه
فانقتل رفيق الحريري
قلت هل يمكن انه يكون مستهدف حدا كان
المدير العام عبد الرحمن الراشد
انا عبد الرحمن الراشد عم بقلك بتقولي
انقتل
رئيس الحكومه رفيق الحرير مرات حتى لو انت
مذيعه اخبار في اشياء بتوقفي عندها انه
انت بذيعوا ولا لا
في احداث بتاثر عليك كانسان في احداث
بتاثر عليك بتكوينك الشخصي وبثقافتك
وخلفيتك وتوجهك السياسي او ايماناتك والى
اخره شو بتامني فيه
وهون التحدي الكبير انه كيف فيك تتعاملي
مع هذا الخبر احنا حكينا عن العراق انا بس
بدي اقول انه بالفتره هديك كونه عم نحكي
عن البدايات انا بتذكر كان انا منتهى
بالنشره ونشره هي بتخلص ساعه انا بطلع
ساعه انا بطلع ساعه وكانت الدوامات طويله
وارجع البيت كنت كان ريان حبيب قلبي ابني
عمره 3 شهور فارجع البيت عشان ابني فما
عندي وقت
لالي يعني يا دوب انام لي كم ساعه عشان
اطلع لانه كنا
بتذكر
وكان لازم 24
يطول بعمرها ماما كانت تحضر الاخبار
بالليل انا بس انام وافيه الصبح واكون
رايحه على الشغل تصير هي تقول لي قالوا
عشان اكون جاهزه للنشره اللي نقدر نغطي
لانه انت شو اللي بميز ما بين المذيع
والمذيع الاخر اللي هو متابعه التطورات
والتفاصيل الدقيقه اذا التفاصيل الدقيقه
راحت من عندك انت لما تطلع على الهواء وعم
تحكي احنا بنطلع لايف بنتي عندك ببطل في
عندك اي شيء بدك تستعملي كل المعلومات
المخزونه
في منه بكون فيه تفاصيل صغيره اذا مرت
عليك خلال النهار راحت عليك انا بقول سوري
الله يطول بعمرها للوالده حبيبتي الله
يخليك
20 سنه مرت في عمر العربيه
واحنا الحمد لله انه كنا موجودين والحمد
لله انه بعدنا موجودين بهذا الصرح الكبير
بس تعرف عشرين سنه قديش غيرت العالم 20
سنه احنا بنتحدث عن من الفين بدايه 2000
ديسمبر 2010 بدايه ما سمي الربيع العربي
واحنا هلا 23 فانت بتحكي عن 12 سنه 13 سنه
تغير فيها شكل العالم العربي
ما بنسى وشكلنا يعني صرنا احلى
بس انه هذه بالمناسبه يعني خبراتك اذا ما
بينت عليك كمان هذه هذه ماسات انا بقول
انه احنا يعني بتذكر كنت اعمل بالبدايات
لما كان طالب يعمل نشرات الاخبار قبل ما
اعمل نشره اخبار انا كان عندي برنامج اسمه
بالمرصاد واشتغلت على هذا البرنامج فتره
بعدها بكم سنه اخذت برنامج بانوراما
واشتغلت عليه
اذكر تماما اللحظه اللي
اجا الخبر بالبروديوسر بلغوني انه في تونس
في فوضى شايفين طائره الرئيس عم تطلع
فسافر زين العابدين
وانا بدي اقول
سافر زين العابدين من علي ولا هرب زين
العابدين بالعالي ولا
شو العباره اللي لازم استخدمها
غادر لانه بدات الاخبار تقول انه غادر
يودي عائلته وراجع فانه كيف غادر بطائره
مع كل هذا الحراك وبده يرجع مره تانيه
فالفكره اه الفكره انه تتالت بعدها
الاحداث من دوله لدوله لدوله لدوله وانت
تتزخم وصلت طائره الرئيس المخلوع او
الرئيس الفارس زين العابدين بن علي
هلا هلا ما تقولي لي انه احنا اللي عاصرنا
بال 2003 حرب العراق بكل الديتيلز
والتفاصيل اللي فيها عنا عند الشباب اللي
انولدوا 2003 نفس المخزون الفكري والثقافي
تبع هذا الحرب يعني انه يستلم اخبار او
بريك نيوز او انت عندك بديل شو اللي صار
شو كانت الجمله اللي واعي صح شايف
وهذا اللي شاهد عليها
وجودنا هون هو اكبر دليل على احترام
الخبرات اللي موجوده بغض النظر عن وجوه
الجديد اللي بتطلع او غيرها وشغله ثانيه
جدا مهمه من انجازات العربيه اللي موجوده
هون نسبتها عنا اربع نساء مع رجل واحد مش
انه الرجال اقليه ولكن ولكن انا دائما
بقول
عن مليون
طالب بس انا اللي بقوله انه العربيه وضعت
المراه صفوف الاماميه ان كان فيما يتعلق
بالشاشه ان كان فيما يتعلق بالميدان الله
يرحمها
نجوى نجوى عم بحكي يعني حتى الوجوه ذهبت
الى الميدان ريما مكتبي غيرها من
المراسلين والمراسلات طبعا في تركيز
بالتساوي ما كان في انه الرجل هناك او له
مكانه محدده
كنا نشوف ز لالنا في يعني مرمى النار
حتى في الاداره
الام بي سي هلا بصوره عامه وهذا اللي انا
بحكيه عن ثقافه الام بي سي اللي نشرتها ان
كان ثقافه انسانيه او في نوع من الدعم
للمراه والمساواه والى اخره واللي هي
بنستمدها من هاي الثقافه اللي ترسخت
مؤسساتيا
من السيدات من اول الاتش ار لاخر العربيه
بعدنا عم نحكي
العربيه
قديش نتاثر او هذا هاي شغله تجربه شخصيه
انا مريت فيها لانه انا جيت بعدكم على
الاخبار زي ما ذكرتني وانا كنت في البرامج
ودخلت على الاخبار في عز الربيع العربي
يعني في اسوا
الاوقات لما كانت تيجي صور لاطفال مقتولين
في سوريا مثلا استخدام سلاح كيماوي غاز
كيماوي انا اكيد اكثر من مره على
انا اختنقت مليون مره
قديه صعب انه نقدر نفصل لكن خليني اقول لك
شغله
احنا بني ادمين احنا مش روبوت ابدا نتفاعل
نتفاعل مع محيطنا بصوره عامه والانسانيه
هاي ما الها حدود مش وطن واحد هي باي مكان
بتصير بس انا بقول يمكن الله يرحمها اطوار
بهجت بهداك اليوم كان درس شوي علمني عن
حياتنا احنا بعض الناس بقولوا عنا مفصولين
وانا رفقاتي امران بقولولي انت مفصوله
يعني معقوله ما يعني ممكن تكوني عم تضحك
كثير عم تبكي بقول لها يمكن طبيعه عملي يا
اجبرتني انها تكون قادره على السيطره على
مشاعري باوقات محدده يوم الطوار بهجت انا
بتذكر الله يرحمها كان في دوره تدريبيه
لالنا كمذيعين وكان شخص جاي يعلمنا كيف
فيك تفصلي لنفسك لما يجي عندك ضيف انا
فلسطينيه يجيني واحد اسرائيلي مثلا بدي
اعمل معه لقاء كيف تفصلي نفسك
وشعورك عن التعاطي مع هذا الرجل اللي
امامك بغض النظر بتحبيه يمكن يكون شخصيه
بتحبيها او شخصي تكرهيها
وصلنا خبر الله يرحمها اطوار بهجت وتحولت
الجلسه الى جلسه دعم نفسي الرجل اعد
وعملنا سيركل وصلنا نمسك ايدين بعض وصرنا
نبكي كان عندي نشره يومها وطلعت بدون
الدموع اللي كانت كنا على الارض خلص
يوصلوا يشربونا مي نارنا صراحه يعني وطلعت
قدمت النشره بكل قدراتي اللي هي موجوده
رغم الحزن الموجود فانا بقول انه على
الممارسه وعلى الخبره الواحد بقدر يحاول
يسيطر
بس متابعه لكلامك انه ما فينا اظن حدا
بيقدر ينسى احنا لانه بنشتغل بهذا المجال
بنشوف الصور اللي تحت الهواء بتعرف
القوانين العمل بقول لك انه هذه الصور
قاسيه فما بتنعرض او بتتغطى احنا بنشوفها
طبعا يعني ما فينا اتوقع حدا بيقدر ينسى
الصوره كيف مثلا معادل [__]
انا يومها في حدا قال لي ما تشوفي الفيديو
قلت لي ما فيني اطلع على الهواء وانا مش
عارفه شو صار عشان احكي لان كان عندنا
تغطيه فتحنا الهوى كله انا والله
التكنولوجيا اللي استخدموها والاخراج
والكذا ما انت بدك تعرفي تفاصيل التفاصيل
حضرتها وطلعت على الهواء فبترجع لموضوع
انه هذا يعني مرات بحس واحد انه والله انت
نجم تلفزيوني
يعني قديش انت بتعاني مرات لما بتشوفي هيك
مشاهد
وتتاثر ويمكن حتى من غير ما تحس تتاثر
مرات حتى بتروحي تحاولي تنامي وما بتقدري
بتضلها
بكل جثه للاسف يعني
يحسدوني على موتي واسفي حتى على الموت
لاخله من الحسد انه في ناس حتى على الحروب
وعلى هالتغطيه الماساويه بيحسدك انه انت
عم تغطي لا نحن عم نقوم بالعمل هلا بدنا
نقوم بالعمل على اكمل وجه انه نطلع كانه
والله حجر بس مش عم تاثر بس بيكون من
دواخلنا يعني بعض يمزقوا بعض
على الهواء لدرجه
تحديدا
عشان ما يكونش نحكي بس نتذكر اشياء موجه
ه بدنا نتذكر اشياء جميله برضه
صغير
وبعديه في نشره رياضه بس بهذا الموجز
بنقول للاقتصاد فانا نقلت للاقتصاد صرت
ناقله ومخلصه صار لانه عم يجهزوا للرياضه
الفيديو وول تحول رياضه مش اقتصاد جزء منه
رياضه جزء منه اقتصاد فقالوا ميسون ادلب
ادلب للي ما بيعرف بالاعلام انه ارتجلوا
احكي وصرت ناقله انه اقتصاد فبديت اقرا
شو النتائج انه
بعض الاسواق الماليه
باللون الاخضر يرتدي
الحكي لانه الاقتصاد لما اعطيت النشره
لفاطمه اعطوها دقيقه يا حرام فهي حكت
خلصت النشره تاعتها عملت هيك عصبت لانه
عندها معلومات بدها تطلع على الهواء كل
واحد بحب لما يطلع يقدم المعلومات المهمه
القيمه اللي عندها وهي من اهلها هلا التيم
كله راح يجهز
للرياضه فاطمه معصبه جاي تحكيني شو اللي
صار معها انه قدام عصبية وانا عم بعمل هيك
انه
انه روحي فاطمه انا عندي هواء وهي جاي
ومعصبه وهيك فالمهم فانا بطلع هيك انه حدا
ينتبه علي انه هي جايتني وهاي ما حدافا بس
وقفت لعندي اكتشفت انه هي قدام الكاميرا
فنزلت على الارض هون بعدني انا عم بحاول
امسك حالي وحاولت اعملها بضحكة إنه فاطمه
مصره تكمل النشره بس هي مسكينه ما عرفت
وين تروح فراحت للجهه الثانيه خبطت
بالكاميرا الثانيه انه هاي اللي على
الهواء صارت تنط من كاميرا لكاميرا وعم
تعمل هيك وتقول لي سوري وانا على الهواء
برازات تطور سياسي فاطمه مصره تيجي على نص
المشرق فرزه تطور سياسي على طريق
المفاوضات لتشكيل الحكومه
ههه مشاهدينا
الحكومه العراقيه الجديده تمثل بطرح
ههه
سنكتفي بهذا القدر من هذا الخبر ولكن نكمل
ان نشرح حيث بدا الكونغرس الامريكي دراسه
مشروع قرار يقضي بمواجهته فانا خلص هون
يعني خلص مع صعب الواحد
يومين لانه كتير صعب وهذا اللي عم نحكي
عنه قصه الضغط النفسي للمذيع بتعرض له لما
انت تفقدي سيطرتك على الهواء بكاء او ضحكا
او باي حاله من الحالات لما تسمعي خبر
محزن وتنزل دموعك تنقهري مهنيا انك
على مشاعرك مش سهله
على قد ما هي بتبان
حلوه والناس بتحبها
على قد ما هي صعبه بالذات في المحطات
الاخباريه انت مسؤول عن الكلمه يعني انا
لما بدي اسال سؤال بختار الكلمه اللي
بالسؤال لازم تنحط بدل ما الكلمه هاي يعني
اذا بدي اقول صراع احسن ما اقول نزاع ولا
نزاع احسن من صراعه المعنيين مختلفين عشان
لانه موقفك انت بيطلع وبنفس الوقت كانه
الضيف بياخذ منك وبرجع لك فانت كيف بدك
توجه الحوار طيب طالب شو ابرز ما تغير
باخر 20 سنه او بالعشرين سنه من انطلقت
العربيه
يعني هذه الثوره الرقميه غيرت كتير من
مفهوم الاعلام
يعني نحن لما جينا
الى دبي بال 2002 لنكون صريحين كان في
محطه واحده اخباريه هي زميلتها يعني قناه
الجزيره لكنت محطه ناجحه ورائي كمان ونحن
كنا عم نتهيا لنطلع ما كان في الفضاء
العربي محطات اخباريه متخصصه كيف في محطات
منوعه يعني فيها جزء صغير من الاخبار ولكن
وكانوا عدد قليل مع الثوره الرقميه هلا
الان عندك حتى عم نحكي على الفضائيات
المتخصصه يعني الفضائيات اللي بتعمل اخبار
في عندك فوق المي
طيب نحن عم نحكي كنا محطتين محطه
هي موجوده وناجحه ومحطه في طور بدها تطلع
اللي تغير انه نحن جينا على على مكان كان
بعده ما فينا نقول انه
هالمنطقه عملنا محطه اخباريه والحمد لله
تركت بصمتها وكانت نجاحها يعني منقطع
النظير ثم بلشت الثوره الرقميه اللي نحن
بلشنا عم نعمل
يعني انت لكن في عندك سمارت فون لكن عندك
وسائل التواصل يعني بالالفين اللي عندك
فيسبوك لعندك تويتر لعندك ولا شيء طيب هذا
طرح عليك تحدي انه كيف سرعه التاقلم او
لانه اللي ما بيتاقلم
هيموت مثل الجرائد الورقيه اكبر تحدي انه
نحن ننتقل من مفهوم انه قناه اخباريه الى
مفهوم الشبكه ونتاقلم مع الثوره الرقميه
يعني اول ما جينا لهون حتى انت ما فيك حتى
الجوجل سيرش ما كان بعده يعني عم تحكي انت
كنا بعدنا بننطر اللي بيجوا على مكان ابدا
هلا شوفي انت وين عندك يعني ما حقول لك
ملايين البلاتفورمز اللي بتجيبي منها
المعلومات وبعدين انت قديش بدك المحتوى
وقديش انت بدك تنفسي معهم
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
كلمه باللغه العربيه انا عم شوف الفضائيات
الاخرى هلا طيب اول شيء على مستوى اللغه
على مستوى الصوت على مستوى الاداء على
مستوى السياسي قديش هذا بيقرا كل يوم يعني
المذيع اللي ما بيقرا 60 70 صفحه باليوم
بيجي عم نشرح فيه المذيع اللي بيكتب له
هذا المذيع لخيره فيه كمان هذه العربيه
يعني جابت فلي من المذيعين كانوا يعني
جاهزين لهذه المهمه اللي عم شوفو الان
بالفضائيات الاخرى مثل عم تقول انه مش
مشكله انه والله هذا انتشروا صار مشهور
مشهور شيء بس بهدفوليستيك يعني هذا شعبه
شو عم يعمل بس هل عم يعطي ماده مفيده
للعالم
بس الصحافه رح يضل ان طلع كاميرا ولا ضل
داخل الكاميرا الصحافه صحافه صحيح
ليه لانه هي بتضلها راسخه في الذاكره لانه
هودي مضبوط عملوا حضورهم هيك العربيه
الحقيقه واسمحي لي ادخل بجانب شخصي
العربيه ما بتحس انك في مكان عمل تحس حالك
جاي على بيتك كلنا بنعرف بعض كلنا وجوه
اكلنا مع بعض
واحد ايوه وعزينا بعض وواسينا بعض وفرحنا
يعني
[موسيقى]
عارفه كيف فكره انه انت يعني انا كثير
اكثر شيء تقولي لي شو اكثر شيء ممكن يحزنك
ويخليني فعلا اتاثر اذا واحد من زملائي
استقاله راح على مكان اخر يمكن هو شاف انه
هذا اخر احسن يمكن هو بالنسبه له احسن بس
انا كانه حدا من من اخواني سافرت او حدا
من اولادي سافر
يعني كيف بدانا من الخطوه الاولى عشرين
سنه مش قليله يعني انا جيت بنتي عمرها 21
سنه
في انطلاقه حتى حياتنا الشخصيه
شفنا عائلات
احتفلت الجمهور بعدني بتذكر
مرحله مهمه بقصه الصوره النمطيه للمذيعه
وقدمناها مش على ستايل لانه
بتفاصيل حياتي اليوميه وخرجنا عن الصوره
الجميله
حمل بنتها لوالدتها ببرنامج صباح العربي
نرجع قبل انه هذا المكان سقفه وشهد عائلات
ولدت يعني انت
تزوجنا نحن وبعد ما طلعت العربيه بتكم شهر
بنتي اجت بال 2004 وبنت الثانيه 2007 هي
السنه اللي انا بطلت فيها انواع الكاميرا
لكن
بس بحب اقول لك انه
العربيه انا فتت فيها مذيعه انا انتقلت
بروديوسر تطورت لسينيور بروديوسر
يعني العربيه ما حددتك
شخصيه تلعب مثل ما قال طالب شخصيه الانسان
علمه ثقافته كذا بس اذا ما لقيت الفرصه
اليمين
يتلقفك ويقول لك انه اعطيناك فرجينا
ممكن ما اثبتت نفسها بجدارها
عائله
في شغله كمان راويه معاه اذا في ضيف كمان
الامن الوظيفي اذا استخدمنا هذا المصطلح
يعني انا نادرا ما اشكر انه العربيه اضطرت
الى ان تصرف هي موظف وبعدين كانوا حريصين
دائما ان الكل يعيشوا بجو عائله وحتى كان
في نوع من السياسه انه كان في مدير اخبار
السابق الاستاذ نخلي الحاج مجال وتحيه
مثلا كان عنده سياسه بيعرفوها الزملاء اذا
شاف حدا مثلا احد الزملاء
قاعد بالزاويه زعلان
كان دكتور نبيل الخطيب كمان يروح ويسال
ويخيبكشي انت اذا مزعول بدك اجازه خذ
بحاجه لزوجه كان في هذا الجو الحس
الانساني عرفت فهذا كمان بتحسي انه هذا
الجو انه الواحد يشعر بالامان انه جاي على
المؤسسه مش انه في صيف
مسلطته وانتبهوا اي غلط انا بقطع في شيء
ثاني طالب انا ما بحب انه نخلص هاي الجلسه
بدون ما نذكره الحقيقه انه هذه هذا المكان
برئاسه رئيس مجلس الاداره الشيخ وليد
الابراهيم اي حد مش لا سمح الله مش انت
اللي تكون مريض لو انت كان حدا من عايل
عايلتك محتاج ولا محتاج معالجه مره دائما
دائما
الجانب الانساني
غير انه طبعا الشيخ وليد الايد البيضاء
موجوده هو عززوها بثقافه المؤسسه احنا عنا
ام بي سي الامل اللي هو بشاركونا كموظفين
معنا ومع اولادنا بنشاطات انسانيه وهذا
جزء من العمل الخيري اللي يضاف لمؤسسه
الماضيه انا بذكر وانا شاركت ببعض من هدول
الحملات لام بي سي الامل لما كان اولادي
موجودين صحيح وبرضو لما صاروا
الانساني بحب اقوله وهاي يمكن ما بعرف اذا
وصلنا للنهايه بس بحب اشكر العربيه انه
سمحت باطفاء الانسانيه وبشكل مكثف على
نشره الخامسه لمده خمس سنوات
باطار طرح القضايا الانسانيه اللي احنا
ترقينا فيها مش بس مجرد نقل الخبر السيء
عن الجانب الانساني او حتى الفرح بنجاحات
البعض ولكن وصلنا لمرحله ان نصل الى
بيوتهم كمذيعين لانه المذيع ربما جميل جدا
الاضاءه الموجوده حواليه والاستديو اللي
حواليه ولكن الاجمل ان يلامس قلوب الناس
ببيوتها وان كان بالمعاناه او بالفرح فهاي
كانت اضافه جميله جدا بس بشي صغير عشان ما
ارجعش احكي مره
ثانيه سؤال
بعد 20 سنه
اثرنا في اللي حوالينا اثرنا في الراي
العام كان صوتنا مسموع كنا موجودين على
الساحه كانت الناس تشيرلنا بالبنان كانت
الناس تفتح الريموت كنترول تشوف العربيه
اذا قالت هالخبر ولا لا نعم سعداء فخورين
بانه بالعربيه وراح نضل باذن الله سعداء
وفخورين بمثل هيك ممكن اختم بعد هيك ختام
أنا
بعد المسيره الطويله نحنا هنطلع من الشاشه
يعني وارجعوهم فايده
لو سمحت احكي عن حالك
انا بس بدي اوصل بدهم ياخذوا هالمهمات من
الزملاء انه نوصيهم بالعربيه خيرا
لانه هي محطه بتستاهل
المواهب اللي عم تيجي جديد انه يعرفوا انه
هاي العربيه
وقداها المحطه ناجحه وقدها المحطه هتعطيهم
ويحافظوا عليها مثل خيرا
كتير في اشياء ممكن تتغير ممكن شكل الشاشه
يتغير اللوجو يتغير الاستوديو تتغير الناس
تغيروا فادنى زملاء عزيزين علينا وفي
زملاء جداد انضموا لالنا ولكن في كثير
شغلات برضه ما بتتغير لا هدفنا لا هويتنا
كمان كالعربيه راح تتغير ولا رسالتنا راح
تتغير نحن الشجره كل واحد بهالمحطه محطوط
اسمه
محمد
مش ورقه نحن جزاع يمكن اولادنا يجوا على
هالمحطه ما بتعرفي وراح نضلنا موجودين
ونحنا موجودين اطلقناها ولساتنا موجوده
متابعينا بهيك انتهى وقتنا بشكركم جزيل
الشكر على متابعتكم لحلقتنا الخاصه جدا
بمناسبه عيد ميلاد العربيه العشرين بتمنى
انكم استمتعتوا معي ومع زملائي الاعزاء
اخواني
وطبعا اللي معاي في نفس البيت من 20 سنه
وبنتمنى انه هذا البيت يبقى دائما مفتوح
للجميع شكرا شكرا
[موسيقى]